the Aon is reasonably comfortably
controlled B5 that was
the yes how much time did he take on
that not that long for such a commit
decision wow yeah pretty certain that
he's been thinking about on Richard's
time by the way that is for me um an
indication of what a great player leavon
aronian is for seriously uh for the
better part of the entire game he's
played it in this passive I'm keeping
I'm keeping but Underneath It All he
also says let me explore my chances when
I get the chance and this is why I was
so uh I might even use the word upset
even though like this is a kind of a
parasocial relationship that is not very
healthy for you but I felt that he's
really not doing himself Justice by
defending in the way that he was
defending because he is one of the more
imaginative one of the more exciting
players around